well this halloween nasa and spacex are
launching three american astronauts and
one european to the international space
station here to talk about the
incredible work crew 3 is doing is nasa
astronaut laurel o'hara she's live from
houston good morning laurel thanks so
much for joining us it's nice to see you
good morning
good morning i'm excited to be here well
and you and i were talking a little bit
during the break you're excited for
other reasons too because you personally
know a couple of the astronauts that are
on this crew that are blasting off on
sunday you have can you tell us what
they must be feeling right now
oh i this is just super exciting it's
super exciting watching them get ready
and um i really can't believe it and i
know they're probably having a hard time
believing it too like they just got
their spacesuits at ksc for the first
time with their names on it and uh one
of them said you know this is actually
like dreams are turning into reality and
so i think it's just kind of this pinch
me moment for all of us really uh
getting ready for this launch and and
the space program has changed you said
you're fairly new to the space program
since 2017. three of these astronauts
are rookies can you talk about the
partnership now
between nasa and spacex and this new
space for commercial space exploration
that we've never seen before until
recently what does this mean for the the
future of space travel and exploration
yeah that's a good
this is really the dawn of a new era in
space exploration
we are seeing more people fly to space
more often
doing more research and also even for
tourism than we ever have before so this
is we're really launching this new era
in space exploration and this
partnership between nasa and american
commercial companies is changing
everything we do about low earth orbit
where nasa is looking forward to just
being one customer of many for these
companies as we look forward and see
more people going to space wow i i grew
up nasa was the only way to go that was
the only way to get off the earth was
was with nasa but not anymore i think
we're going to see more and more
opportunities for everybody to go to
space and experience it sure seems like
it uh so what does this crew hope to uh
accomplish when they go to the
international space station
so they're going up there to live and
work for six months and they're going to
do all sorts of science and research
they'll be doing
a lot of work involving plant science
health health science and health
technologies
new space suit technologies that are
going to enable future exploration of
the moon and mars
and even research on our own bodies to
learn how the human body uh lives and
works in space so
it's a whole wide range of research that
will benefit both our future exploration
programs with the artemis program and
also life here on earth oh my goodness
well we're so excited we're so excited
for them uh you're too or your
classmates and so uh good luck to them
and of course we wish them a god speed
uh just quickly where can people watch
where can viewers watch the launch
so viewers can tune in
we'll be live on nasa tv starting at 10
pm eastern on saturday the launch will
take place at 2 21 am eastern on sunday
october 31st and we'll be live on nasa
tv all the way from launch
until docking and hatch opening on space
station with the astronauts come on
board and greet their crewmates
you can also follow along with mission
updates on our commercial crew blog at
nasa.gov and with the hashtag on social
media of hashtag crew3 all right laurel
o'hara thank you so much we wish them
nothing but treats no tricks for
halloween launch
and i hope they have a blast i hope they
really have a wonderful time thanks so
much for sharing your insight and can't
wait to see you
on one of those missions as well soon
good luck thank you thank you
oh guys it is just going to be fantastic
don't you wish them well three rookies
and one veteran you said i hope they
have a blast but they're gonna be an
enormous blast until they get up there
that rocket just started getting them up
into space that was kind of
tongue-in-cheek
but they've named their capsule
endurance so they let the astronauts
name they let the crew name their
capsules oh that's nice for the spacex
program so uh yeah you're gonna have to
have a lot of endurance if you're gonna
be living at the international space
station for a while six months i mean
that's a long time and it is interesting
to see what will happen to the human
body as she mentioned because i think
and the human brain in your mind right
you know what's it like
up there i mean people have been doing
it for quite a long time and it's
obviously survivable and you're healthy
and all that kind of good stuff so very
different yep you brought up a good